COLT MCARLIS: In this episode
of Cloud Performance Atlas,
I help some bacon lovers
profile Kubernetes Startup Time.
We'll their performance end
up with the perfect crunch?
Stay tuned to find out.
After my work with
the foodie picks team,
another food based
company approach
me to help with more cold
boot performance problems.
Bacon Live is a mobile
network for chefs,
where you can watch live video
feeds of people cooking food,
annotations included.
The back end for Bacon
Live was using Kubernetes,
which is a great tool to help
you manage, contain, and deploy
images to your various instances
in a seamless and powerful
manner.
Sadly though,
reporting back details
on cold boot performance was
not something it did easily.
So before we could solve
Bacon Live's issues,
we had to figure out how to
profile pod startup time.
After digging around,
neither the cloud console,
stack driver or heapster
surfaced any direct numbers
with respect to the
boot time for pods.
There was, however, a single
place where some startup time
information was being surfaced,
in the Kub Control Get Pod
method.
It turns out that
calling this function
will return a JSON string with
some time-stamped information
relating to the
pod startup phases.
Here you can see
that the pod status
emits the scheduled,
initialized, and ready phases,
each with a time
stamp that tells
us relatively when it occurred.
So for this example, you can see
that it took about one second
to go from initialized to ready.
So we can at least get some
information about how long
things take to boot.
Now to get a sense of the
average startup performance
and what it looks like, we
need to create a loop, where
we kill the current pods,
let new ones boot up,
read their time-stamp
data, and then repeat.
Do that about 100 times
or so, and we end up
with something that looks
like this, which shows us
that for a blank pod, it
takes about three milliseconds
to boot it up, which by the way,
is a lot faster than booting
a compute engine instance.
And the reason for that is that
when a Kubernetes pod boots up,
it's not starting a
brand new VM each time.
It's just booting containers.
See Kubernetes pods are made
up of a series of containers,
which provide endpoints and
services for the instance
itself.
A pod is considered ready
once all the containers have
been initialized and
their health checks pass.
Now to help facilitate
proper boot up,
the initialization process
breaks up containers
into two main groups.
The first is the Init Group,
which initializes specific
containers in a linear .
Order
The second is the
Parallel Group,
which initializes the remaining
containers all at once.
The setup has some
interesting quirks and chances
to be problematic.
For instance, if a single
container during the init phase
takes a long time, it will block
loading of everything else.
So to understand where a pod
boot up performance is going,
we need to be able to
time the specific startup
duration of each
container in each group.
So let's start with
the init containers.
After a bit of digging, we
found that the Kubernetes
get pod command will return
the status of the target pod
during boot up time.
And when you have the
init containers defined,
the Status field will list the
status of the init containers.
For example, a status
of init 16 indicates
that one of six init containers
has completed successfully,
which means that we can pull the
pod every 10 milliseconds or so
and get a sense of how long
each stage is taking to boot up.
When we graph that
information, it
becomes really easy to see that
for this example, the database
initialization and stats
frameworks are taking
the longest time to boot.
Now timing the
parallel containers
is much trickier, since there's
no time stamp or extra data
emitted when a container
makes a transition
from initialized to being
ready to handle requests.
So in order for this
information to be surfaced,
we have to probe our endpoints,
much like health checks
or readiness probes would.
These systems sit in a tight
loop and touch the end points
until a specific
response is received,
which lets the load balancer
know that this container is
ready to handle traffic.
So for our set up, we
modify each container
to expose a new
entry point, which
returns the string "success."
Repeatedly, we're
pulling this end point
from an external location,
yields three different states.
First is error, which
means that the service is
not up or running yet.
Second, is code of 400
or 500 series, which
means that the
service is booting,
but the end point is
not available yet.
Or finally, "success."
If we pull the end points
every 10 milliseconds or so,
we can figure out how
long the container sits
in each of these states and
chart it as a pretty graph.
So armed with this
information, we
could finally start looking at
what was causing Bacon Live's
performance problems.
But for this episode,
we're out of time.
If you'd like to
know more, check out
the rest of the Cloud
Performance Atlas content.
And remember, when it
comes to performance,
every millisecond counts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]